[DEEP BREATH]
INTERVIEWER: What
is your ritual?
JAMES ARMSTRONG: My ritual
is meditating and breathing.
My breathing is as
long and as slow.
At times, it can feel like
an out of body experience.
It's given me a lot of ability,
I would say, to do things.
Anything.
Whether you're stressed,
or scared, or keeping calm
is a big deal.
INTERVIEWER: How long have you
been in the Hollywood stunt
business?
JAMES ARMSTRONG: I've been
a stuntman for as long
as I can remember, to be honest.
I'm second generation.
My father and my uncle
were all stuntmen,
and I grew up around it.
But we're a weird breed.
We enjoy hitting the ground
and smashing through things.
So there's a million ways
to turn a stuntman around,
and I've probably done them all.
On a big, full body fire burn,
I might have as many as five,
six layers on.
And I like to alternate
between dry, wet, dry and wet,
just because it interacts
differently with the flame.
So I've got all
these layers on me.
They've got fire
retardant on them.
They've got fire gel on them.
They're cold as well.
That affects your breath
when you're breathing.
[DEEP BREATH]
INTERVIEWER: Do you still get
nervous before a big stunt?
JAMES ARMSTRONG: Oh, for sure.
I get nervous about everything.
The smallest things.
People die doing stunts, and
you learn the older you get, OK.
I'm scared, I'm nervous,
but this is a good thing.
It means I'm thinking
things through.
When you're there and
they're all looking at you,
it's incredible, the pressure.
You have to kind of
get into the moment,
switch on, and do it once.
Get it done, you know?
And we have a saying.
Fear knocks on the door,
but experience answers.
INTERVIEWER: What happens
if you lose focus?
JAMES ARMSTRONG: If I'm
about to do something,
and I feel my heart
thumping or my hand shaking,
then I'll close my
eyes, and I breathe.
[DEEP BREATH]
The fear all goes
away at that point.
There is no other
distraction, no other thought.
It's just this
absolute pin point
focus of the task at hand.
When I open my eyes,
I'm ready to go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
INTERVIEWER: Click to watch
how one boy's ritual has
made him feel less different,
and ignited a passion.
SUBJECT 1: Sports
is very important.
It's where I go to
relax, and that's
what I do to get
everything off my mind.
I've learned to be
confident in myself,
I've learned to be positive.
I'm different.
That's not a bad thing.
INTERVIEWER: Rituals is
a part of Seeker Stories.
If you'd like to
continue to see more
stories from around the world,
we need you to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.